in this case study we're going to go
into may be excruciating detail showing
you how I really am not always sure
about which point of view I'm going to
be taking with these micro needles I
just place them on my table just to take
a look at it to kind of get a sense of
what they look like I even went further
and put them on top of the petri dish
which they came in just to sort of study
it I actually don't mind this image as a
final image I was surprised but as
you've seen before you've seen the
microneedles placed on the flatbed
scanner which does produce a really
wonderful image I then decided to also
then go back and refine the arrangement
there are two colors that the
researchers decided to distinguish
between showing pink and clear just you
know looking at the depth of field here
I'm starting to compose for a cover shot
in this image I did the same thing
thinking about a cover but just using
one color I thought that the pink was
distracting in this next image I just
refine the color bit which we could do
in software in this image I'm still
looking at a point of view look
carefully as I slightly change the
positioning of the disk in the lower
left watch as I go back to what I
previously had and just very ever so
slightly change it so that it doesn't
become redundant with the other
arrangements these are very very many
changes but this is sort of what you
have to go through in the end the
interesting thing was that the
researcher sent me a very wonderful
microscopic picture of these micro
needles and he really wanted to try to
get a cover and although this
course is about a camera and a lens I
thought it'd be interesting for you to
see the possibility of creating a
potential cover submission from a
horizontal picture I really do encourage
you to consider doing these kinds of
things we're not changing the
microneedles we're just changing the
background of the microneedles and so
from this initial shot we in fact did
get the color